hey everyone and welcome to another HD
tutorial this one is going to be very
simple and fairly intuitive it's built
into Windows Vista already and as you
can see by that title up there I'm going
to show you how to change this picture
right here in your window does the Start
menu works only in windows vista it's
really really simple all you got to do
is click on that year and it will bring
up right into the the whole user and
family a cake safety accounts and user
account just have that change your
picture kind right there so you don't
like the pictures that are built into
Windows Vista what I'm going to do is
hit that button that says to browse for
more pictures as I'm browsing I'm just
going to I already know what a picture I
want to use so I'm just going to go into
my computer here and find it pictures
logos BAM hit open and there we go that
is my actual picture so now whenever I
go into my start menu or I'm logging
onto my computer that is the logo that's
going to show up in my start menu so
that I hope that was held for free guys
and thanks for watching this video
tutorial peace